best-selling author john grisham is
considered the master of legal thrillers
his novels you know them pelican brief
and a time to kill
look at that board have sold more than
300 million copies look at his work
now he's swapping the legal court for a
sports court
silly is grisham's first basketball book
it tells the story of a player from
south sudan
his big hoop dreams and his challenges
off the court
john grisham joins us from the
university of virginia's john paul
jones arena it's a home of the cavaliers
at 2019 ncaa men's basketball champs
we'll talk about us left for basketball
in just a second but john grisham good
to see you let's start with this
so an author walks into a sports bar
with some friends
he looks at the tv screen he sees what
and what does he do
well good morning gail good morning tony
and anthony
what happened to me when i saw it i said
like everybody else i was in shock that
march madness had been canceled i didn't
know you could do that we were all
depressed we were
working on our brackets and arguing
about number one seeds and uh
having a beer and a bar and suddenly
there was no march madness and so
i had the idea for a basketball novel
i've been kicking around for a couple
years and that was sort of the uh
impetus to start writing it and the goal
was to write the book and
have it out by march madness this year
yeah and you said you like sad sports
stories john
so tell us about suli
who is he well we can't spoil it we
can't spoil the ending gail uh you know
you know
what that means may i be on record
john can i be on record with this
because clearly you didn't consult with
renee
your partner of many many years about
the ending i was very disappointed
i totally disagree and i did not like
the ending of this book but i like you
so go ahead but you yeah but you read it
and enjoy the book
[Laughter]
i like i like uh i love sports stories i
love sports it's college sports
especially
and i like the sad sports story so
that's i've written a few of them now
and sully turns out to be pretty sad
yeah yeah he does i mean you take us on
quite a journey with him and you're
there at uva which by the way i didn't
know you were such a basketball fan but
look
the back page of the book shows you and
who wears short shorts
you john grisham clearly a high school
basketball star back in the day
but you spent a lot of time with the co
look at you
who where wow you spent a lot of time
with the coach
uh with tony bennett what did you learn
from him while researching this book
because you got the basketball high
school basketball
you called me a high school basketball
stud
okay we'll go with that it was not much
it was not much of a career that
photograph you see on the dust jacket is
me playing basketball
uh when i was a junior in high school i
started for our high school team
uh that team won one and lost 24.
and uh we got some bad we got some bad
we got so
we got some bad calls but we're not very
good and so that's when i quit
basketball after that season
because the whole team was coming back
my senior year and i didn't want to go
through that again so i quit basketball
and
walked away and the team won a bunch of
games the following year
uh but yeah we we come to all the uva
games here
at jpj and uh tony bennett's a good
friend and we
admire him greatly and the program that
he has run here it's uh something we're
very proud of
yeah i can tell that john i can tell
that okay we want to play basketball we
want to play up your basketball skills
quick quick buzzer beater greatest
player of all time
a college or college or pro john just
anybody
anybody john college would do pistol
pete
pro would be michael jordan favorite
basketball movie
hoosiers favorite basketball rivalry you
show
you throw great shaded duke in this book
i do not approve but
best basketball rivalry
carolina duke is the greatest college
basketball rivalry ever
it really is ah all right john grisham
what have we got for jeff we got one
more we need to we need to ask him uh
what's next for you yeah that's right
your next project what's coming up next
yeah
yeah i'm in the middle of the next legal
thriller i start in january and finish
in july so i'm halfway through with it's
called
it's called the judges list it's a
another juicy legal thriller with dead
bodies everywhere and
that's you know that's what i enjoy
writing comes out in october i know but
the basketball book was great fun john
congratulations we got to see a whole
nother side of your personality john if
you want a viral video to promote this
book you better shoot a shot right now
yes
here's your chance i am not i am not
going to shoot a shot i'm not going to
dribble i'm not go i can't even pass
i'm not going to do that you look good
you're looking for the book of sully
we'll be right back